okay today we're gonna be looking at
scp-1361 special containment procedures
scp-1361 a humanoid containment cell at
site 19 the presence of four security
personnel is required prior to entry
restraints may not be removed unless
specifically required for testing for
communication purposes scp-1361 and
notebook description scp-1361 animate
fully articulated Android scp-1361 point
eight three meters tall and weighs a
hundred kilograms - white pea mm a
circles approximately three centimeters
in diameter represent the androids eyes
scp-1361 II is composed of molded
polycarbonate casings over an aluminum
frame these casings are covered in a
black fabric of unknown composition
referred to as scp-1361 this covering
acts as a skin and has a universal
thickness of one centimeter the serial
number zero three one is woven into
scp-1361 in a red variant of scp-1361
testing to identify scp-1361 a SIL
Pharma with limited success
the material is a type of aramid fiber
with a tensile strength of approximately
4,000 MPA along with the gravity of 1.1
making the material lighter and stronger
than Kevlar the material is self
repairing with adjacent damaged scp-1361
fibres reweaving and fusing back
together scp-1361 is also capable of
repairing damage to scp-1361 at casings
as scp-1361 fibres will fill in damaged
areas during the repair of the outer
covering all samples of scp-1361
disintegrate after 48
hours of separation from scp-1361
screwing the tip of the finger and
include a steel needle attached to a
roll of red thread made from the same
material as scp-1361 left thumb a roll
of Patchett's made from the same
material as scp-1361 5.1 centimeters
wide left index a pair of miniature
steel fabric scissors right thumb a
steel scalpel right index both middle
and ring fingers are hollow and serve as
storage space the CP 1360 is intelligent
and displays a clear knowledge of
unarmed combat and firearms usage it is
obsessed with escaping and subsequent
return to an entity it refers to as
anderson SCP 1362 feel pain despite its
apparent lack of a nervous system it
claims that this pain is the result of a
component having been removed prior to
containment
and as a result views itself as
incomplete despite being incapable of
speech scp-1361 fluently interviews have
been moderately successful they'll
escape and repair our favourite topics
of conversation
addendum 360 - a the following message
was recovered on a flash drive with an
SCP 1360s right middle finger upon
recovery important do not discard
dear James congratulations on the
purchase of your new Peregrine series
humanoid utility droid civilian model
unit 31 comes equipped with the
following standard features
pre-programmed personality number for
hectare full understanding of up to
three languages English Japanese and
German our standard aramid covering and
full self repair functionality as you
discussed with mr. Sager during your
consultation meeting number 31 has also
been altered to include your requested
modifications these include removal of
vocalization capabilities our advanced
firearm skill set and our advanced
unarmed combat skill set like the
Kestrel and Merlin units you have
purchased number 31 has been programmed
to take commands from only yourself and
your daughter in addition it can also
serve as a command unit with your
permission number 31 is capable of
issuing commands to your other droids in
your absence it is important to note
however that unlike your previous
purchases number 31 contains a highly
adaptive artificial intelligence to make
the unit's interactions more human and
personal number 30 one's personality
will evolve over time based on its
interactions with you and your use of
the unit within a matter of days number
31 can become both your daughter's best
friend and your most loyal servant as
with your other units please do not
attempt to repair number 31 of
malfunctioning in the event you become
unsatisfied with the unit's performance
please lock this flash drive back into
place within the right middle finger
storage compartment and speak your
return phrase number 31 will then
automatically return to one of our
facilities and you will be contacted
with more information on replacing or
refunding your purchase as always it's a
pleasure doing business with you
Anderson
addendum 1360 - be on the 17th of
november 2009 following a fourth failed
escape attempt the following note was
found in scp-1361 signal terminated
we're better off keeping you where you
are we're sorry
number 31 Anderson as of this date
scp-1361 with fundation personnel in
addition scp-1361 sticken tainment and
scp-1361 collection that was scp-1361